Okay.
Wow.
They should coexist alongside each
other.
They shouldn't intertwined.
I think part of the difficulty is that
one man's faith is another man's heresy,
or one woman's faith.
There's another woman's Harrison.
I'm the chief rabbi of England,
recently wrote a book called the dignity
of difference.
Jonathan sacks.
He was actually contemporary of mine at
Oxford,
and he wrote something that has stuck
with me.
He said,
there's only one truth in heaven,
but there are many truths on earth.
Well,
you know,
truth is supposed to be indivisible.
You know,
it's,
it's binary.
Either it is or it isn't.
But once you accept that there was more
than one truth on earth,
then you can't say,
it has to be my way.
You know,
I believe there's a divine power.
There's a God and God will figure it
out,
but that's in heaven.
And so mixing religion and politics,
um,
is a pretty dangerous admixture in my
view.
[inaudible].